as much as I hate to say it we are not
done talking about big publishing
they're the ones responsible for getting
in second graders hooked on popper fuel
bestiality orgies shame on you mr.
Popper's Penguins now the book East us
have aimed their sharpest pencils at one
of our great conservative thought
warriors former Breitbart senior editor
milo gianopolous now if you don't know
milo you clearly haven't been living
under the correct rock is the alt rights
Premier Agent Provocateur who
effortlessly triggers liberals with
unparalled us three genders
there's man woman and retarded being
Muslim for instance almost as stupid as
being fast feminism is cancer thank you
very much I know you're thinking I gotta
hear more from that guy and bigwig
publishers Simon & Schuster agreed
giving Milo a six-figure book deal
shortly after Trump was elected now a
few months later those literary kook
teases killed Milo's book deal
why left-wing media bias take a look if
the press gave me the same kind of love
attention and lavish praise which is
they give to Lena Dunham and Amy Schumer
completely undeserved on the basis of
nothing these are talentless warthogs
you know if they gave me that level of
gushing attention because I'm the same
just for different politics really I
wouldn't have sold a couple of hundred
thousand books I'd have sold a million
yeah my look is the same as Amy and Lena
between the three of them they have an
Emmy a Golden Globe and a lifetime
Twitter ban for racist Lee trolling
Leslie Jones exactly the same but Milo
will not be silenced like the free
speech Crusader he is Milo is suing
those book loving bastards for ten
million dollars but here's what just
dropped Simon & Schuster's public court
filings which include Milo's original
manuscript with the editors notes last
week those notes hit the Internet and
they are mildly unflattering
but now snowflakes and SJ double media
celebrating like Whole Foods is having a
clearance sale on matcha tea here to
talk more about Milo's persecution by
the left our citizen journalist Josh
sharp and Aaron Jackson thank you thank
you
there panties over this editor shady
notes but the truth is giving Milo an
editor in the first place was fascist
yeah he's a free thinker he shouldn't be
bound to totalitarian publishing ideas
like common decency or basic book
structure aaron and i have never used an
editor we just quickly write down what
we want to say feed it into the
teleprompter and then say back whatever
is ribbon on there that's what free
speak is all a pouch I put in a Green
Laurent guys yeah
and while the soy boys on social media
are going gaga with this editors
takedown the truth is that a lot of
these notes are pretty standard in the
mainstream publishing industry so let's
go through some of these notes Milo got
from his editor yeah hmm okay here's the
first one delete irrelevant and
superfluous ethnic joke that's a totally
standard now the editor on little women
said the same thing the character of
Beth was originally in blackface for the
whole book yeah or how about this note I
don't like using Nazi analogies ever
okay everybody gets this one it was one
of the early notes on Animal Farm
it's actually why Orwell decided to make
them animals the first draft was just
about Nazis on a farm and it was called
Nazi farm
some more editorial feedback Milo got
when he wrote about pizza gate this
entire paragraph is fake news there was
no blood no semen and no Satanism delete
you know who got this note all the time
dr. Seuss here's an early Cat in the Hat
draft there was blood on the stairs
there was jizz in the bath then the cat
summon Satan who unleashed his wrath I
love that and it's great for kids okay
now my love got lots more notes but
again they're all standard stuff like
dumb jokes dander note delete a standard
no this is a stupid way to end a
terrible chapter a class at the time nor
the place for another black dick guy I
know I asked you guys this all the time
but when is the time and place for a
black dick joke now that the book is
canceled for now okay it's justice right
I can't believe they pulled this book
just because he made some pithy
observations about women Muslims trans
people black people fat people gay
people people no Jordan the book got
pulled because Milo made some rather
provocative comments about pedophilia
yeah all that hate speech Estep is the
reason he got the book deal in the first
place yes so you can cool it with your
woke Twitter parades about the Simon &
Schuster clap back libs because these
notes were not written by some heroic
social justice warrior no they were
written by a professional editor who was
part of a team willing to pay Milo gobs
of money for his ideas so that Simon &
Schuster would make gobs and gobs of
money off of Milo's ID gobs and gobs all
right Jordan we have to go we're off to
read the racy unedited version of hop on
pop to some kids yeah and yes Jordan
it's about exactly what you think it is